brexit has been a rough passage as
berkshire knows
in the town of imouth we've been
charting progress
and it's been slow at this fish
exporters
business transporting shellfish and
longest into the continent
has been patchy they're now exporting
half the amount they typically do
that's the ones that went to boeing last
night pictures beamed back from remote
cameras on board lorries
show their journeys transporting the
product on the continent
they also show how this business has had
to adapt the camera in the back of the
truck
shows the blue water tanks now the
seafood is transported in water
to keep it alive through delays at
customs it means a lighter load
we're getting a level of success which
we can we can live with but you know
again it
still feels like a lottery if your name
comes out the hat you get through and if
not
you're still stuck most of imo's fishing
fleet is tied up because of rough seas
even if it was out it would struggle to
sell its catch at the moment
because of the paperwork that has to
travel with it and problems that can
sometimes need
an 800-mile car journey to resolve
we had to get the health authorities
here to resign certificates
then have to jump in the car and run to
portsmouth with a new certificate for
the truck so you can make the journey
over
so 800 miles round trip there are few
parts of this industry
unchanged brexit has stripped it back to
the wood
pallets on what they used to be now they
have to be heat treated
and earning the ht branding makes them
three times more expensive
we have ended up with a trading regime
that has become
complex costly slow prone to breakdown
at its best
and at worst that the door to the eu
market's been closed all together for
some food exporters across scotland
and elsewhere in the uk and
unfortunately it's a very predictable
outcome
of trying to test a multi-billion pound
new trading system
in real time in the midst of a of a
pandemic
dr collin trucks took part in the
industry's recent protest outside
westminster
the case has now been made inside to the
scottish affairs committee
brexit was ever the hard sell and so it
continues
in so many ways james matthews sky news
in imouth berkshire